alright let's assess this thing
[Applause]
all right series 11 is done I am gonna
have later this week a ranking of my
thoughts on the episodes you know
ranking 1 to 10 everything that went on
this series but first I want to give
sort of more a more general overview of
my thoughts on the series as a whole
because obviously I've been going
episode by episode as it's gone along
and I've mentioned some of my overall
thoughts and various episodes but I kind
of want them more collected and focused
here so where do we begin well let's
start with Jodie Whittaker as the doctor
I'm officially fully on board with her
as I mentioned in my review of the
series finale it was literally the last
moment of the last episode that got me
to go like I get it now I got it I like
I get her and I get what we're going for
and like thinking on it now like it's
not like she did something in that
moment which if you haven't seen that
that episode review was at the very end
which is like you know the universe can
surprise you you know sort of that
excitement I joined the exploration and
what she might find and sort of latching
onto that it's not like she didn't
express that earlier in the series it
just didn't click for me as like being
her thing I think maybe partially
because it's something that we've gotten
glimpses of from other doctors as time
has gone on but I feel like it's getting
much more the focus here with her and
that sort of finally registered with me
at that point so I strongly suspect that
going forward I will enjoy her more than
I have been because I feel like I kinda
I kind of get her now and that's and
that's cool and that's fun I mean her
performance has been good up to this
point it's been solid but I I'm much
more I'm more excited to see more of her
than I am to revisit the episode she's
already done
the three companions I came away with
exactly what I was afraid of it's too
many and despite the fact that her one
major highlight episode was one of the
best episodes of the series if you're
gonna tell me to cut somebody I would
cut yes it and then I think this is also
part of the reason why it took me longer
to connect with this doctor then I think
it probably should have which is that
with four characters in the TARDIS four
new characters four people we've never
met before all sort of elbowing each
other for highlight moments and
character development ultimately the
most developed characters over the
course of this series are rant our RAM
Graham and Ryan and that's not an
automatic bad thing in and of itself but
it first makes me go I kind of really
wanted to get more of a highlight on
this doctor and then you know he has I
just and again she wasn't bad and
honestly if we were in a situation where
she was the only companion I'd probably
like her a lot but there's something
about her sharing the space with
everybody else she just feels the most
superfluous Graham I do like the best
and I probably Ryan is the one I would
like the least if it was only him like I
like Ryan because I like his dynamic
with Graham and I like their the
development of their relationship over
the course the series but I don't like
Ryan especially in isolation I like him
kind of as a double package so yeah I
three commands I I still say is too many
now now that we have kind of gotten a
handle on all on all three of them and
the doctor maybe it won't be too many
going forward but to it but to have all
of them show up at once and to have to
be developing them intangibly the each
other I don't think that was a good call
I think it would have made a lot more
sense if
this series we did either only as or
only Grammy Ryan and then added whatever
one wasn't there at the beginning either
towards the end of this series are at
the start of the next I think starting
with three companions I think that was a
mistake
but overall my my frustration with this
series because it has it has been a bit
of a frustrating series as that on paper
a lot of the decisions being made sort
of at that the 10,000 foot level and the
you know the big overarching decisions
that chip mill is made are ones that I
like at least on paper doing standalone
episodes and not doing a strong over you
know a ton of emphasis on look at the
recurring thing we're gonna pay off
across the series good I'm so sick of
those good awesome
no no returning villains great I need a
break from them terrific and then after
after that you know we've got a lot more
emphasis on the doctor in the companions
then on the monster of the week fine
monster the week is should not always be
the focus anyway all only like to
actually episodes set on modern-day
earth most of it is either in other time
periods or a planet great love that the
doctor the doctor isn't constantly
running into people who she's met before
and they haven't all heard of her good
awesome so like there's a bunch of
large-scale decisions about the way the
series went over all that I like and yet
somehow didn't result in a series that I
would have expected to have liked as
much you know given that these calls
were made and I do think Bank it does
come down to the episode by episode
writing to be blunt about it
Chibnall wrote the worst episodes of
this season
and I think that's kind of a that's a
bit of a red flag when you're showrunner
is producing the weakest writing now
that doesn't mean he has no value cuz
like I said I think the the larger scale
decisions he's making are not bad ones
and potentially even very good ones if
executed on properly but it really does
feel like other writers are executing on
these ideas better than he is that said
and I have this as a fairly easy
comparison to make because in doing my
overdue Doctor Who review stuff I've
fairly recently wrapped up doing series
one this series in more than a few ways
reminds me of series one because I mean
let's be honest about about a few things
they're the best episodes of that series
we're not written by the showrunner
either and then that and both in both
cases one of the better episodes written
by the showrunner was the finale
although I do think the part of the ways
was better than Battle of did I can't
whatever the heck it was so but the the
I sort of feel the similar growing pains
going on here that I felt from series
one like is trying to get its its feet
under and it's trying something out that
and maybe like series went too serious
ooh it'll recognize what wasn't working
and shift accordingly because a lot of
the a lot of the you know most grown
were the elements of series one didn't
carry over you know the you know the
things like the the plastic been eating
Mickey and burping or the farting aliens
that kind of stuff
was largely dropped like a little of it
showed up in series two but then by
seriously basically all that had been
shed and so I mean I'm kind of hopeful
that might be the case here obviously
completely doing different showrunner
Chibnall is not Davies so like I'm not
going to say oh he'll do the same thing
I'm just saying
I'm looking at the precedent from
earlier series of this modern era
revival going okay this is trajectory
where this could get better and yeah
that's sort of my my big thing is that
and I mentioned this already in my
episode where I talked about the fact
that Chevelle is coming back to do
series 12 and it's that I kind of want
him to take a more supervisory role like
make the make the big meta decisions cuz
honestly I think the casting is solid so
his involvement for that has been fine
I think a lot of the large-scale
decisions you know putting the the the
classic villains on ice so that when
they inevitably do come back it'll have
some more weight to it hopefully you
know although all those things are good
look you know large-scale big-picture
decisions maybe just keep him from
writing the actual script because that
does not seem to be his area his he seem
see and and I worried this after having
watched the first series of broadchurch
chip know as a writer I'm not
necessarily as a like a show runner or a
conceptual guy but as an actual writer
seems to do best with relationships and
character dynamics and interactions
because even if you look at the Doctor
Who episodes that he's written that's
usually some of the stronger stuff going
on there I mean even if you think of
something like the power of three the
ending is a complete cluster but the
dynamic going on between the characters
is actually pretty dang good stuff so
and that's kind of a strong suit and it
wasn't broadchurch as well and he got
away with it in broadchurch because it
was it was in a not exceptionally
remarkable mystery story where what was
gonna make or break that story was how
good are these characters whereas here
we're dealing with bigger sci-fi
concepts so we expect the stories and
the plot mechanics to function better
than he seems to be capable of doing
because he in
episodes the character stuff has been
pretty solid and you know different
showrunners have different specialties
though that's been true before I mean
Davies had a lot more of emphasis on the
emotional end of things
and whereas Moffat was much more
interested in the plot mechanics and the
way things fit together and sort of the
possibilities of the sci-fi angle
whereas Davies like I said was a little
bit more into the melodrama of it one is
not inherently better than the other but
each has their strengths and it's best
when they stick to that because I mean
God sync when Moffat tried to do like
dramatics and soap opera he stuff it was
painful like Moffat go back to your like
carefully in you know constructed
wind-up toy episodes you're better at
that and the I think the problem is
though with with Chibnall
is that they had he doesn't seem to have
found a plot guy an episode template
that allows his strengths with character
work to shine but also enables him to
get a decent actual story going so like
again if I were to go back to Davis who
like I said I don't think was nearly as
good at plot and certainly not sort of
the overall plot mechanics as Moffat was
but part of how he made up for that was
by going for more operatic plotting as
opposed to sort of intricate who hears
this Syfy concept that we can do weird
things with he was more likely to go
here's this you know grand epic thing
you know let let's go a little bit
bombastic with it let's you know let's
let's blow this stuff up you know he's
sort of going for for scale and
spectacle and not even necessarily as a
bandage or a way to cover up his writing
but just sort of as a way to facilitate
what he was good at
and I just I just don't know if Chibnall
at least over the course of the series
has found a way to facilitate his
strengths in a way that doesn't just
counteract them because I I do have to
lay a lot of the issues on the writing
because I do think that's casting a
solid I think the directing has been
phenomenal the music Wow not nearly as
memorable as Murray Gold's was is has
been fine it certainly does the job
alright and you know effects have been
good guest performers have all been good
but there's just something about a
decent number of these scripts and
definitely the ones that chip doll
himself has written that just isn't
quite there yet
like the concepts are mostly solid the
progression for characters is good but
like it needs it needs tightening and
needs punching up it needs a go over by
someone who can sort of goose the actual
plot mechanics of it and I'm not sure
how to fix that you know other than like
I said have chip and I'll take a more
supervisory role and not actually write
as many scripts but I mean they're gonna
have more time to work on the next
series so who knows I'm I mean I'm
definitely not abandoning the show I I
don't know if where I would place series
11 in terms of like my rankings of a
series overall I feel safe in saying
it's it's probably yeah it would end up
bottom half I don't think it's at the
bottom but it's definitely lower half as
a series overall which again is
frustrating for me because there have
been good individual episodes and a lot
of
good general directions for the thing
that just aren't panning out the way
that I would like them to that's kind of
where I'm at with series 11 on the whole
what do you think about the series
overall just please remember no personal
attacks on me or anyone involved in the
show I will not only delete your comment
but if I catch you doing it more than
once I'll bang you off the channel cuz I
just don't have time to keep dealing
with that crap but as long as you can
avoid doing that whatever your thoughts
are and you can disagree and think the
show is not good just be polite about it
drop something down the comments let's
talk about it over just something you
can do because there's buttons and
there's links including one to my
patreon if you feel like supporting me
and this show in that way if not there's
other links to check out don't want to
click on those that's fine too because
at the end of the day you're the council
I just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]